THINGS.
WE'VE NEVER BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING HIM HERE.
SINCE MIKE BERGERON BY
SENATOR RAND PAUL.
HE SERVED WITH SENATOR GRAHAM.
REP SINCE THE COMMONWEALTH OF
KENTUCKY AND HAS A FANTASTIC NEW
BOOK OUT CALLED "THE CASE
AGAINST SOCIALISM."
RAND PAUL JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO BE
UNFAIR TO ANY PARTICULAR SENATOR
BUT I WOULD TELL YOU THAT I HEAR
A LOT FROM OUR VIEWERS.
WHAT'S THE ANSWER?
HOW DID IT START?
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN.
HE CLAIMED HE WOULD GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND WHY HASN'T HE?
>> NOT JUST ANY SENATOR CAN DO
THIS.
I CAN'T CALL COMMITTEE HEARING
ENTERING THESE PEOPLE IN.
SENATOR GRAHAM HAS THE POWER.
HE SET CHAIRMAN OF A POWERFUL
COMMITTEE, JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
YES, I'VE ENCOURAGED THEM
PUBLICLY AND PRIVATELY TO DO
THIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE JOHN BRENNAN
COME IN.
I WANT TO SEE BRENNAN TESTIFY
AND I WOULD ASK HIM VERY
POINTEDLY DID YOU TALK TO THE
BRITISH INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
AND DID YOU SET UP SPYING BY
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES ON
THE PRESIDENT OR THE PRESIDENT'S
CAMPAIGN?
I THINK HE DID NOT THINK THAT'S
AGAINST THE LAW.
I'VE TALKED TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONVINCED THAT THESE PEOPLE
WHILE THEY MAY BE DECEITFUL,
THEY ARE SORT OF, YOU KNOW, SO
OFFICIOUS THAT THEY PROBABLY,
PAPERWORK THEY FILLED OUT AND
PHONE CALLS PROBABLY HAVE A
RECORD BUT I THINK HE DID CALL
THE BRITISH AGENTS AND I THINK
HE DID GET THEM INVOLVED.
I ALSO THINK IT BE INTERESTING
TO NOTE CRIST FOR STEALING THE
STEELE DOSSIER, DID HE TALK TO
RUSSIAN AGENTS?
THAT'S BEEN A RUMOR FOR OVER A
YEAR NOW.
THAT HE WAS GETTING INFORMATION
FROM RUSSIAN AGENTS.
SO EVERYTHING THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
ACCUSED PRESIDENT TRUMP OF
DOING, YOU KNOW, INVESTIGATING
UP LOCAL RIVAL WITH A FOREIGN
COUNTRY, ALTHOUGH SAME QUESTIONS
SHOULD BE ASKED OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
DO THEY DO THAT TO TRUMP?
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
WE ARE BEING TOLD WE HAVE NO
RIGHT TO KNOW THE ANSWER AFTER
TWO YEARS OF SITTING PATIENTLY
LISTENING TO THIS NONSENSE ABOUT
RUSSIA.
SO LINDSEY GRAHAM IS AT THE
CENTER OF THIS.
YOU WANT TO GIVE HIM THE BETTER
FOR THE TOP OF THE QUESTION
REMAINS WHY IS NAMED ON THIS?
IT'S IN WITHIN HIS POWER TO DO
IT AND HE HASN'T DONE IT.
WHAT'S THE ANSWER?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO WAIT AND
SEE.
I THINK HE WANTS TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF BUT YOU'RE RIGHT HE
NEEDS TO EXERCISE THE POWER
WORKS.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING A LONG TIME
ON THIS.
SOME PEOPLE I'M NOT GOING TO SAY
SENATOR GRAHAM ARE THERE OTHER
REPUBLICAN SENATORS APPEAR WHOSE
ALLEGIANCE IS MORE TO THE
DEEP STATE THAT IT IS TO THE
PRESIDENT.
I DO THINK SENATOR GRAHAM DOES
LIKE THE PRESIDENT AND WANTS TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT BUT A
LOT OF US WANT TO SEE IT GET
STARTED.
WE WANT TO SEE SUBPOENAS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE EVERYTHING
BEING DONE IN SECRET ON THE
OUTSIDE AND THEN THEY PARSE OUT
WHAT THEY WANT TO PARSE OUT.
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
TESTIFYING OVER THERE COULD
EQUALLY BE ASKED TO TESTIFY OVER
HERE.
BUT REALLY I WANT TO SEE BRENNAN
COME IN.
I WANT TO SEE THEM UNDER OATH, I
WANT TO SEE THEM UNDER OATH.
>> Tucker: I SEE A PATTERN
HERE, THOUGH.
AGAIN, I DON'T WANT TO BE MADE
IS UNDER GRAHAM HOWEVER KNOWN
FOR LONG TIME AND I THINK A
SMART AND CAPABLE MAYBE THAT'S
MY FRUSTRATION AS HE IS SMART
AND HE IS CAPABLE OF WHEN HE
GOES ON CABLE NEWS ON THE SHOW
BUT ON OTHERS AND HE MAKES THESE
CLAIMS I'M GOING TO DO THIS ON
TO DO THIS I'M GONNA DO THAT,
I'M FIGHTING FOR YOU.
THEN HE DOESN'T.
HE IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
HERE'S LINDSEY GRAHAM PROMISING
US VOTERS IN AMERICA HE'S GOING
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE RAID
ON ROGER STONE'S HOUSE.
>> MY JOB IS TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AS THE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO WATCH THOSE
WHO WATCH US.
MUELLER, DO YOUR JOB.
THESE TACTICS ARE UNACCEPTABLE
GIVEN THE LEVEL OF THREAT.
I'M SENDING A MESSAGE TO THEM.
YOU ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
CONGRESS.
THEY BETTER ANSWER MY LETTER.
IF I WERE THEM, I WENT.
>> Tucker: SO HE DIDN'T IN THE
END GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
RAID ON ROGER STONE'S HOUSE.
WHY SHOULDN'T WE FEEL AGGRIEVED?
>> HE NEEDS TO USE HIS CLOUT,
AND ONLY HE CAN DO IT.
SOMETIMES THEY GIVE THE
ARGUMENT, THEY SAY WELL WE ONLY
WANT TO DO IT AT THE DEMOCRATS
WILL DO IT IN A BIPARTISAN WAY.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THAT.
SIMPLE MAJORITY CAN VOTE TO DO
ANYTHING IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
I THINK EVERY ONE OF THOSE
MEMBERS WILL VOTE FOR HEARINGS.
I THINK THERE SHOULD BE VERY
HIGH-PROFILE HEARINGS ON THIS.
THERE'S A LOT TO INVESTIGATE.
HOW THEY ORIGINALLY GOT THE FISA
WARRANT.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT ANYONE ELSE IN
AMERICA TO BE ABUSED BY A
GOVERNMENT WAY PRESIDENT WAS.
THIS COULD HAPPEN TO ANYONE.
>> Tucker: I'M WONDERING IF
THIS IS SOMETHING TO DO WITH
ANOTHER ISSUE UNRELATED DIRECTLY
TO THESE ISSUES WHICH ITS
FOREIGN POLICY.
SENATOR GRAHAM, AS YOU KNOW,
REALLY PROBABLY THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE NEOCON IN THE SENATE.
HE'S BUTTED HEADS WITH THE
PRESIDENT OVER THIS.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY ARGUING ABOUT
SYRIA.
I WONDER IF HIS DISAGREEMENT
WITH TRUMP ON FOREIGN POLICY
QUESTIONS HAS CAUSED HIM TO SLOW
WALK SOME OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> THERE IS AN ESTABLISHMENT IN
FOREIGN POLICY AND ALSO IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY TRULY
IS THE DEEP STATE.
THE DEEP STATE HAS AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF POWER TO LOOK AT
INDIVIDUALS AND SO WHEN GRANDMA
AND I HAVE FOUGHT THESE FIGHTS
IN THE PAST, I HAVE ALWAYS
THOUGHT FOR HAVING WARDS WHERE
REAL JUDGE IN PUBLIC HAS TO, YOU
HAVE TO PRESENT PROBABLE CAUSE.
LINDSAY HAS ALWAYS FOUGHT FOR
ALLOWING THESE TO BE DONE
SECRETLY.
THESE FISA WARRANT, ALLOWING
AMERICANS TO BE CAUGHT UP IN IT.
THERE MAY BE A CONCERN THAT IF
WE LOOK AT THE INTELLIGENCE
DEEP STATE, AS WE FIND OUT
THINGS, THEIR POWER MAY DIMINISH
EITHER MY PFL PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCE THAT HE WANTS TO
MAINTAIN THE POWER AND THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: IT MAY BE AN EYE
THAT YOU THE VOTERS OF
SOUTH CAROLINA DISAGREE WITH HIM
ON THAT.